bom a última ideia porque não jogar
pingue pongue com iluminado e muito 010
é no concelho illuminati não podem ser a
lei olha eu aprendi com nitinho no
ensino mas carol
ae
o lado pessoal aqui quem fala são é
cuidar dos frangos e eu mostrei aqui é
um negro chegar ela aí por que vocês
pedem muito muito mesmo não tendo mais o
que não é nada comum ligado ao qual ante
8 a lei tem um louco médio eo à noite
isso não é jogo em 3 a 1 os pães muito
não sou muito burro cagão no adro
teclado
pessoal vamos lá cruz anos gabriela
never esta é a nossa fé o nosso espaço
nossa casa está ali algumas já têm a ver
alguns vídeos diz portanto isso não é
completamente novo primeiro nem o último
intervir e só perceber porque é que eu
tinha de fazer e e o que poderia fazer
mas pra descansar vamos la presse é eto
o pan o oponente que a opa no carro pois
claro da quinta desde que abriu a porta
para seguir vez um pessoal incluindo
solta né
já tem um papel aqui do que no início ou
não você já tem indicação de um corpo
ali só aumenta o volume também porque eu
sei que este utente boa muito ruim
alguns chute totalmente um sonho fica
comigo que o consumo máximo vai pedra
desapareceu
não passarei a ruminar de sopot sua foto
nos abrir a porta presença do nosso bom
tanto uso ea em abril criado após agora
a princípio uma ótima de óleo já caiu
agora é só abrir a porta o qual quero já
não sou eu mexer a boca de sino e
supostamente o meu quintal aqui dentro
não sei cara burro que não esta é minha
casa porque eu tenho a chave para ela é
porque essa é minha casa o sintoma
música pessoal sintonia musical música
do amanhecer por uma música ouvida mas
39 coisa estranha ao ou um fantasma sofá
e já agora só comendo tem aí nos
comentários
o primeiro deles comentários negar que
os comentários se é pra todos cometem
nos comentários coisas pra fazer e que
desafios do ministério resolveu não saiu
está muita gente fazer isso portanto o
jogo é isso né eu estou agora a vida me
que sim é sempre um sofá foi vista em um
hotel vizinho mas já o conhecia não
gostar e 50 já o conheço há aí está
trancado a chave tem um cartão estava
trancada ou já não vou conseguir ser
casa no uruguai que opte por hotéis
também enxerguem o alguma coisa por ela
lê ou do shift turnê em um córrego na
rua boa é isso que eu preciso proteger o
vizinho em we walk to eye que sua filha
da [ __ ]
este espaço pra frente diz possui uma
tela preta
cerca de cerca de cerca de 5 não tinha
nada
o hospital espera importantes humanizado
estão em minha casa não só entrou quando
alguém eu tranqüilo e qualquer coisa
dentro
já percebi porque este é cheio de
mistérios pois claro o que agora aponta
[Música]
bang entrou entrou literalmente para
dentro do armário e não viu o gol e não
conseguir dinheiro
agora o gado foi solta na casa já não
esconde dentro do armário e eu espero
que este mundo até mesmo por favor
ai eu faço viu
eu posso que opera espera um pouquinho
agora sair outra vez fui cuco não é
pouca coisa que eu continuo falando do
consultório meu carro acabam trair 30k
ainda não se sabe a causa de como eu nem
entrei na casa dele eu nem entrei na
casa dele e eu só vinha atrás de mim
como o carro que está na lei e por causa
de um curto o botafogo que o partido já
não só para pegar porque quatro janelas
de casa para apanhar absoluta ainda dele
a própria casa porque essa casa é minha
é muito rápido muito originais de qalay
outra fonte será que se eu correr assim
muito rápido dentro da casa não consegue
pagar
oi eu não viu ele ainda está aqui calma
calma calma não possui agora eu vou te
dizer eu vou te dizer um policial tenha
uma escada deixam sua vez que neste caso
há aqui qualquer coisa será que tem tudo
muito mistério o pessoal não tem nada no
carro aí posso entrar por aqui
cozinha equipada de ouvir
elba atendendo o cheirinho ver neca
como é que eu eu eu é muito rápido não
dá para fingir não dá pra fugir na
embaixada do brasil
foi tudo um pouco porque o meu no
maracanã está muito medo que eu posso
fazer o que eu possa entrar e escolher
vai ainda gostava de ver o mestrado
posso jogar o jogo não só por quem posso
chegar só um pouquinho
até o cachorro não pega a terra tem um
cachorro meu estilo tático e ensaio
eu entro dentro de casa já olhar pra mim
lá eu tava previu i say [ __ ] não
quero vai te embora
não sério vai ficar a olhar pra mim o
dia todo a busca pelo vizinho xiita os
músicos tão bom no final eu voltei pra
casa já aguenta porque a entrega os que
tinham uma janela partida aqui em casa
seu quarto domingo enquanto o estilo de
jogo porque este é o tipo cartune pois
não só a cama estava torta aí perna de
robinson pelo marido para qualquer lado
né
aí eu posso escutar eu posso escolher
acho que houve um tributo pessoal tava
se luxa eu sou o cheque e eu estou
debaixo de uma cama
beber café e não só pessoal e ouvir uma
interface não só sabem quanto com vocês
de algumas coisas para fazer aqui neste
jogo e quatro gavetas só uma quebra
maior porque conseguem mistério só não
vou falar um pouco como está no link
sobre esse jogo eu escutava a espreitar
nas portas portanto eu vou tentar fazer
o que eu me indicou o resulta exato
obrigado aqui mesmo destaque em uma
estratégia de espionagem bastante
gostosa eu adoro espreitar pela porta eu
não tô aqui portanto vamos entrar na
entrada principal característica que a
campanha querendo sul ouviram oxigênio
não tem visto
tudo isso o botafogo tem uma parede ou
estranha essa seja sei que isso é
pessoal é isso mesmo é isso e que
supostamente uma porta secreta que nós
temos cativaram umas coisas lá atrás lá
no quintal e só do projeto de entrar
aqui exposta em terreno de jogo next
portanto tem que vir aqui fora nem
existentes um circuito que tem qualquer
coisa a ver com isso aqueceu ativar isto
que ela porta resposta mentawa não abriu
sob mistério prejuízos que mistério
gente nós só vão exterior se rápido na
época em que o filme lhe vem daqui vendo
aqui ok tem qualquer coisa que é esse é
um gerador é isso mesmo quer desativar
isto já que vai já está está a funcionar
81 escalar o time para cima da casa e
não sair ainda mundo lhe qualquer coisa
eu acho que tem que ter bastante mesmo
só quero voltar outra vez e agora a
porta vai abrir supostamente é isso
olha só olha só vai só ó zé agora vai
agora vai ter a linha e isso muito lenta
mas só entre o caracter a pomba não há
tempos baixaram eu não sei jogar este
jogo vai vai
agora vai pôr cobro muito rápido e só
baixou baixas ou baixa
com isso consegui cancelar e da [ __ ] do
corpo só no rodrigo freire e tchau pra
ele o eleito
fui pela boca eu acho que o flamengo
voltou a oi
a mãe o tabu portas lá embaixo tem muita
porta lá embaixo de uma lona vasco
pessoal que o mistério meu cérebro não o
juro que eu vou matar escolha ou não
escala não ficou um pouco
será que eu conversei aqui na boca
isso é fácil vir aqui não posso curto
pra [ __ ] o outro em cima da casa
pessoal tá aí sim mas a casa estava o
vizinho e agora é que manda ontem que um
buraco tão solta solta do que canta só
no cantão de tira e é conseguir socorro
vai conseguir uma câmera tem que entrar
aqui tem outra casa não é muita coisa
aqui tem uma série de portas
outro lado aqui também tem carro eu ia
sendo foco de outro lado meu deus meu
deus
este jogo tem muita coisa eu agora é
possível porque tá muito simples garisto
agora por ser fã
nestas salas de ver o que isto tem
porque eu nem sequer entrei que nunca o
turrão nova york e vou aproveitar e vou
aproveitar só vai só vai ser vai
aproveitar o que é preciso investigar
agora tudo o que é esta é português
resposta muito cartão e preciso do um pé
de cabra passa um carro por furto só cai
para dentro do frigorífico tem alguma
coisa olha as porcas chato porque já
isso mesmo
antes disto quer mais mas todas as
gavetas drogas nada aqui
ele precisa saber o que estava aqui
perto
agora vamos pra que eu entro na outra
sala e depois saio vou tentar usar
aquela coisa
ele andou se dirá atividade paranormal
ae agora vai jogar e conseguir final da
filda só vai só pegar porque não consigo
ter uma maioria no japão nos painel não
sempre a pagar o sinal já não sei vou
fechar portas recordou agora é preso e é
preso em uma armadilha tudo se eu fosse
uma armadilha do sul bok só pecadora
estão que tudo se existem não sair mas
eu vou voar [ __ ] se eu vou só do valor
que já nem sei qual é só vocês eu só vou
conversar
eu só vou correr o jogo correr
consegui encarar o curso de salta só
isso
boa conseguir pagar tudo
não não fui
vocês só com a sua conta do google
gastou 2 x estão sentindo moni por aí
o ritual satânico não só pessoal freire
filho esta porta secreta de uma escola
onde está aquela pessoa que está no
início e gritar
onde está essa pessoa de ficar que nem
ela nem corgan ponto como esta pessoa
que estava fugindo do do vizinho pessoal
e clareamento é um site o site fugir da
pessoa e é isso pessoal chegamos então
ao fim do jogo já sabem como embaixo
pessoal coisa para fazer aqui porque tem
resposta em ter muito mistério aqui já
sabem pessoal aqui do estado vão estar
dois vídeos costas provavelmente ainda
não viram tanto faz e lá e aqui em cima
tem uma bolinha onde vocês podem se
inscrever é só ter carga é gratuito